ROBERT NYMAN:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[APPLAUSE]
That's as much as I can do.
It took a long time.
It might be better next time.
So I've come all
the way from Sweden.
Unfortunately not
a direct flight,
but Google Maps is a bit
optimistic sometimes.
And usually when I tell people
that I come from Sweden,
they asked me about Ikea.
And if you know Ikea, we want
to say, on behalf of my people,
we're sorry.
We are working on it.
It will get better.
And also one interesting
thing to know about Swedes is
that we very shy.
So we have a lot of
feelings on the inside.
But we don't really show
them on the outside.
So I'm going to be
really excited up here.
But you won't be able to see it.
And I've been working on
the web for a long time.
I started back in
the end of the 1990s.
And then about eight
or 10 years later,
I got involved in the
Mozilla community,
building Firefox extensions and
giving presentations and such.
And then I worked for
Mozilla almost four years
as a technical
evangelist around the web
and trying to teach people
how to build good websites.
But everyone has a past.
This is actually a young me.
I'm not really sure
what was going on.
I know it looks like
a Russian dating site.
So don't ask any
questions, please.
However despite this,
I actually have a job.
And I work at Google
with developer feedback
and with communities.
As part of that, I've
been fortunate enough
to get the opportunity
to travel around
to a number of
different countries
and to meet developers
and to try and understand
different challenges
and different contexts
and how we can try and
make things better for you
and also make sure that you have
the right help and tutorials
and guides.
With the web as of today, I want
to start with mentioning that,
because the talk has the
title The Future of the Web.
But I want to talk about
the web as of today first.
And if we go back
about six years ago,
there's something
called Wired magazine.
And they declared the web
dead about six years ago.
And this is kind of tiring,
because it becomes always
this media thing that
something is dying.
And it's a big crisis.
Then of course, interestingly
enough, about six years later
they had a new editor
at the magazine.
And suddenly the
web was alive again.
And you hear these
things all the time.
And if we look only from our
side with Chrome, for instance,
a year ago Chrome on mobile
alone had 800 million users.
About six months ago, Chrome on
mobile reached 1 billion users.
And now Chrome on
mobile and on desktop
together 2 billion users.
And that's only one browser out
of many, many different ones.
So the web is dead?
Well, not really.
We don't worry too much
about the headlines.
And we keep on building.
And we have more and more people
using the web and building
things for the web.
And I think the bad reputation,
especially with the mobile web,
is that this is what
the experience has
been like on the mobile
web for a long time.
You would go into a website.
You would get a big pop up
telling you to install an app.
You've never seen
the website before.
You don't even know if you
want their native app or not.
But this was the
general experience.
But it's been
changing over time.
And if we look now
that on average,
most smartphone users doesn't
install any new apps any month.
So if you're one of the top
few apps, WeChat, for instance,
and a few other ones,
you're really popular.
You have a lot of users.
But most other apps
never get those users,
never gets that engagement.
And we think, also,
the strength of the web
is that it's not just
one company or one
specific platform.
The web is a myriad
of different browsers.
There's so many different
browsers on desktop
and on mobile out there.
And what I will talk
about a bit today
is both learnings that we've had
about the web and also things
that we have
implemented in Chrome
and that we're starting
to implement Chrome.
Not just to talk about
Chrome, but also things
that we would love to see
standardized and things that we
would love to see in
any browser out there.
And also when I talk
about the web as today,
it's generally
progressive web apps.
Progressive web apps is the
entire thing, the entire way
of making sure that we
build really good websites
and then also adding on even
more greater capabilities
that we've seen from
the native world.
And I'm going to go through
six of them really quickly.
And the first one, when we
talk about progress web apps,
we want to see instant loading.
Using something
like Service Workers
to make sure that you
have offline access,
but even more importantly
in places where
you have poor connectivity
or intermittent connectivity,
to make sure that you can have
a faster loading experience.
The next one is
adding to home screen.
As we see with users, having
an icon on the home screen
leads to great re-engagement.
And people just keep
on using the app.
The third one is
push notification.
And that was covered in
Sam's presentation before.
But just seeing
re-engagement from users,
and notifications
can be terrible.
And they can be really annoying.
But if you do them well, they
can be really, really good
and useful for your app as well.
The fourth one is making sure
that your web app is fast.
And it's not only about
loading fast, but making sure
that the animations you have in
the web app is fast and smooth.
And when you scroll
or if you move around,
it's a nice, good experience.
Also that it's secure.
Basically for more or less
any of the new APIs coming out
right now, you have HTTPS.
That's one of the requirements.
And we're also
implementing HTTPS
for older APIs
like geo location,
because we see this as a
really necessary thing.
And we're also experimenting
with some things
in Chrome, because
before, if would access
a website over an
unsecure connection, HTTP,
you would just see the URL.
And then we started
experimenting
with writing in the URL
bar that it's not secure.
And then over
time, it might look
like something at the
bottom that we will actually
really start warning users
that any website that you have
an interaction with
has to be secure,
both for that website's sake but
also for your sake as a user.
The final one, of course,
is making it responsive.
If you build a mobile
web app, mobile website,
you want to make
sure that it works
on any kind of resolutions
from different mobile devices,
to tablets, to desktops.
So in a summary,
progressive web apps
today need to be reliable,
fast, engaging, and secure.
And the core of all
this is making sure
that your users have
a good experience.
Experiences that are good
will have users coming back.
And happy users will
lead to happy developers
and happy companies.
And if you look back
only a few years,
we've come a really long
way on the web and things
that are being supported now.
We had to implement a
number of different APIs
and support a number
of different things.
And more or less, one
of the only things
that you can't do on the
web right now that you
can do native is having contact
access on your mobile phones.
So I really want you to remember
that the web is already all
mighty powerful.
I really hope that that is what
the Chinese characters means.
I should have translated this.
But at the same time,
it's just the beginning.
All those things that
we've done so far,
you see notifications at the
home screen and all of that,
it's just making sure that
we can match the experience
that native has both
offered users, but also
the expectations that are
set with users that this
is what users want.
And we should
bring that to them.
So finally, 32 slides later,
what about the future?
What are the new things
that we're doing?
And when I refer
to the future, I
can talk about very
many crazy things.
But I'm not going to talk
about building robots
from old mobile phones and then
controlling them or something.
When I talk about the future,
and what I think is important
is something that you
can use now or very soon,
something that's
actually coming.
I don't want to say that
maybe in five years,
you will have this.
I want it to be
relevant for you now.
So the things I'll be
talking about today
is knowing who the user
is, credentials management,
paying for things on the web,
connecting with hardware,
physical web, and web VR.
And first, with knowing
who the user is.
It's all about the challenges
on the mobile web with sign in.
And usually if you come
to a mobile website,
then you're supposed to log in.
And you see all of this.
And it's seldom a
good experience,
because when you see this,
you start thinking about this.
Did I use Facebook or Google or
any other account to sign up?
Usually you know
your email address.
You will never remember
the password you
use for this specific website.
So you sit there and
you're wondering,
and you go through the page.
And then you find the magical
link, the forgot password link.
Has anyone not used
forgot password?
Good, we're among friends.
It's OK.
And also a really hard
part is on mobile keywords,
it's really hard to type.
You have a small keyboard.
And getting the right
characters in the right order,
and you're supposed to be
fast, isn't always easy,
which leads to a problem.
Do you know what this is?
Yes, password.
This is the most popular
password in 2015.
Interestingly
enough, it actually
bumped down to second
most popular password,
which had been the most
popular for many years,
which was actually
the word password.
So it's fun.
But it also poses an
enormous security risk.
And especially because everyone
is reusing their password
across websites and all of
that, and if one password or one
service leaks their passwords,
there's nothing you can do.
So one thing that we started
doing from the Chrome side
and trying to see if we
can help from the browser
is introducing something
called Smart Lock.
And now with Smart Lock, we
have about 8 billion sign ins
that we assist through
Chrome every month.
And basically either
this just works for you.
Or as a developer,
you might need
to do really, really small
things in your website,
because generally when a
browser comes to your website
and reads out the forms, it
sees all the different fields.
And sometimes they're
really obvious.
And the browser will know
what to do and what to store.
But sometimes it
isn't entirely clear.
So something that you can use
is the autocomplete attribute.
So you can help the
browser understand
what each field actually means.
So OK, this is the name.
This is the telephone number.
This is the username, et cetera.
And if you have a sign
in form, for instance,
you can use autocomplete
and just specify
that this is the username.
And this is the
current password.
And for sign up forms, when
you're creating a new account
you can have the same things.
But one interesting
part here is you
can see that we have
autocomplete new password
instead of current
password or just password.
And there are two
important reasons for that.
One is if you have
Autofill in your browser,
just making sure that when you
create a new account that it
doesn't reduce what
you already have stored
or something like that.
But a second one, which
is really interesting,
is that if we, from
the browser side,
knows that the user
needs a new password,
we can auto generate
it from the browser.
So for users, instead of them
having passwords like this,
we can give them
this as a password,
I mean not specifically
this, because that
wouldn't be very secure,
because you've seen this now.
But more secure
passwords for them that
might not be easy to remember,
but it will make them safer
on the web.
And we're
experimenting with auto
entering passwords in Chrome and
then deploying it more and more
widely.
So please make sure to
mark up your forms today
with the autocomplete
attribute, because it's
a really small task to do.
But it means a lot for the
browser and for the users
as well.
Then we have the
credentials management API,
which is the next generation
for sign-in on the web.
And we shipped this
recently in Chrome.
It's not in all browsers yet.
And it allows you,
as a developer,
to integrate with the
browsers Credential Manager.
And for instance,
with Ali Express,
they have a really good example
of a good user sign in flow.
Being a shopping app,
it's really important
to be signed in.
But at the same
time, you don't want
to block to user with
having a big login pop-up
or something like that or
blocking the experience.
So as you can see
at the bottom here,
we're offering them
automatic sign-in
on the web, which
is really nice.
And code wise, it's
quite easy to do.
You use something called
navigator.credentials.
And then you call the get
method to get the password
and sign them in.
The interesting
and important part
here is where you see
what it says unmediated.
And what unmediated
means is that it
will be no prompt or nothing
blocking the experience.
It will just be done
in the background
automatically for the user.
For automatic sign-in
and from the Chrome site
to get it to work, automatic
sign-in needs to be enabled.
And you can only
have one credential
saved for that website.
Also as mentioned before, and
as many, many other things,
navigator.credentials needs
to be served over HTTPS.
So it has to be
a secure context.
Naturally passwords aren't
directly exposed to JavaScript.
And also the fetch method
would only submit credentials
to the same site endpoint.
So once you've gotten the
credentials from the user.
You can use fetch and just
send that into the server.
Pass in the credentials, and
verify them, and log them in.
If that isn't an
option for you, you
can use one-tap sign-in, which
is more of having the prompter.
So you go to the website.
The prompt comes up.
You choose your account.
And you sign-in.
And code wise, it looks almost
exactly as what you saw before.
The only thing
that's been removed
is the word where
we had unmediated.
Otherwise it's
just the same code.
And getting the credentials
and sign-in them automatically
is great.
But you also want to give
the developers the ability
to choose when the save the
password prompt is triggered.
When should this actually
come up for the user?
When is a good time?
And the way you can do that
is that you, for instance, can
get a reference to the form.
And then you create
a new password
credential object
and pass in that form
and then store that value.
So again, just a nicer user
experience when it makes sense
to actually store that,
instead of blocking them
in the middle of
doing something.
We also support federated
logins through the Credential
Management API, which
could be Facebook
and Google and other accounts.
And doing that,
it's just creating
a new federated
credential object.
And you pass in the username.
And you also pass in the URL
of the provider for the login.
And the browser will deal
with the rest of the process.
It's also important to
let the user be logged out
when they're done.
And especially if
you're using something
like Autofill or
automatic sign-in,
you don't want to
automatically be sign-in
if someone else loads
it or has access to it.
So you can just call
requireUserMediation
to log them out.
And we've seen a number
of companies starting
working with this already.
And some of them have
it in production.
So we shipped this
back in Chrome 51.
So please try out
these websites.
And try out that experience.
Next I want to talk about
paying for things on the web.
And I think this is probably
the most important topic.
If we see the success
of native apps,
it's been mainly
based on how easy it
to pay for things, to get
apps or services or something
like that, and then just keep
on using what you're using.
And we really need to get
this right on the web.
And with the rise
of mobile computing,
the majority of
commercial traffic
is coming from mobile devices.
And even though it's been
good in native, what's
really surprising is that
still, 66% of purchases
on mobile devices are on
the web, not native apps,
through the mobile web.
So the web, again,
isn't really dead yet.
And we looked at some
countries in Europe
and seeing how many of them
were using the mobile web.
And as you can see,
it's sort of a trend.
It's around 66% per country.
And also a bit small,
but we can also
see, which I really find
interesting digging into,
is seeing four different
actions what users prefer
to use to do that,
if they want to use
a website or an application
or something like that.
So that's great.
People are already,
despite some annoyances,
shopping on the mobile web.
But still we see 66% fewer
conversions on the mobile web
versus desktop websites.
So it's still a lot of
money, a lot of shopping.
But it could be a lot more.
We could to help
users a lot more.
And the reason why it's so much
lower on mobile, of course,
is it's still hard on mobile.
And usually you see
a number of people
just giving up in
the check out flow
when they're trying to
finalize their purchase.
So looking at check out
forums today [INAUDIBLE],
they are manual.
They are tedious.
They take a lot of
time to fill out,
and also requires a
certain amount of taps
to actually get
through all of that.
And on all mobile
keyboard's, if you're
supposed to, for instance, type
in your credit card number,
16 numbers, and you don't
even get the number keyboard
on your phone, it's hard.
And it's annoying.
And people give up.
So again trying to balance
it from the browser side,
we're working with
Autofill, just making sure
that you can start
something in one field
and then just fill
out the entire form.
Because usually when
you fill out forms,
you more or less fill it
out with the same data
as you're done before.
And the way Autofill
works is just
storing the user's
address and credit
card and different
things into the browser
and then having
automatic form detection.
And we see about 95%
accuracy with our Autofill.
And then also if
you want to, Chrome
can synchronize that
securely between
all your different devices.
So for instance, if you
use Chrome on your phone
and your desktop all
your Autofill information
can be synchronized
between those two.
And when it comes to conversion
rate, with Autofill alone,
we now see 25%
increase in conversion.
So that's great.
And then we can't really do
everything to make it happen.
But it's one of the
steps of getting
closer to where it should be.
So Autofill's been good.
It's being more automatic.
And it's making it simple.
But it's still slow with
forms on the the web.
And it still takes a
certain amount of taps.
So imagine a world
without forms.
And it would be
an amazing world.
And that's actually
what we're trying to do.
And with something
called PaymentRequest.
And PaymentRequest is
W3C API to just eliminate
all kinds of checkout paints.
And it's a simple
JavaScript API.
And the browser will take
care of the complicated parts
of the payment.
And you can actually
get a one tap checkout.
And this is also an openly
developed standard API.
Currently it's under development
in W3C Payments Working Group.
And their idea is to create
universal cross-browser
standard for any website.
So this is not a
Chrome only API.
We really want to see it
across all major browsers.
And we see interest from all
the big browsers actually doing
this as well.
For instance, Microsoft have
been doing lots of good work
around this.
And the implementation that
we started doing in Chrome
has been on mobile first.
But then of course, over
time we want to make sure
that it's cross platform.
So it works on desktop
and any other device
as well, and also
that we can support
an open ecosystem of
different payment methods
as well, which of
course is important.
So going back to
the pain of forms,
now with Autofill
and PaymentRequest,
we can get rid of
pretty much everything.
So we can now make it fast and
go from many different taps
to just one tap
checkouts, which is
great I really
think it will change
the experience for users.
And you get much
higher conversions.
And everyone will be happy.
And we like happy people.
Code wise, this is
what it looks like.
So you will create a new
PaymentRequest object.
And then the first
parameter you see
here is just passing in
the different credit cards,
in this case, that you support.
And then the browser can use
the different available methods
and then go through
all the other parts.
These are all the line items
for what you're buying.
And then finally
here at the bottom,
you can set a Boolean whether
you want to request a shipping
cost or not.
And I do want to point out that
our implementation and also
the code that you're seeing here
is based on the first Public
Working draft by W3C.
So it might change.
Most likely it will
look just like this.
But just a heads up that
it might actually change.
So the user experience for
someone going in and buying
something is that when you
choose to pay for something,
this pops up.
You choose pay.
And then with the
shipping, for instance,
if they requested
a shipping cost,
you choose what kind
of shipping you want.
And then you process request.
And you bought something.
Which I think this is amazing.
I think this will
change things a lot.
But of course, credit
cards isn't the only thing.
We're also looking into other
different payment options.
And we launched
Android Pay last year.
And we've seen a really big
growth around Android Pay.
We believe that it
needs to be on the web.
And we see it as even more
secure tokenized version
of your card.
So as we saw before with
different payment methods,
if you want to use something
else from credit cards,
you can just add that
in the first parameter.
So you would have Visa,
MasterCard, et cetera.
And then you have a
URL to Android Pay.
And down here, you can see
all the different parameters
that you might need to
send in to Android Pay.
And the idea with
this, right now we only
support Android Pay.
But the idea over
time, of course,
is to support a number of other
different payment providers
as well, which is vital
to make this work.
So this API should look the
same over time no matter
which payment provider you use.
The only difference will
be maybe different values
you will send in to actually
make the actual payment.
And we started back
in May trying this out
in Chrome Dev on Android.
And then back in August,
we went into beta.
And then we shipped it
in Chrome 53 for Android.
And then next
year, we're looking
to support more platforms and
also support more third party
payment providers as well.
And again, a few companies
have started working with this.
So if you buy something
from these companies online
or through mobile
websites, please let them
know how it actually works.
Let us know how it works.
And let W3C know how it works,
because it's really, really
important that we
get this right.
And we can offer good payment
options for you on the web.
So far we've talked about
making it way easier for users
to log in.
Everything's automatic,
automatic sign-ins, one tap
payment and all of that.
So what about
connecting the hardware?
And the web has had access
to hardware for some time
actually with accelerometers,
game controllers, camera,
audio input and
output, and such.
So when I talk about
hardware, I talk
more about Bluetooth and
devices like heart rate sensors
and similar.
And usually when we
talk about Bluetooth,
you talk about something
called BLE which
is version four Bluetooth.
And BLE stands for
Bluetooth Low Energy.
And looking at the
evolution of transfer rates,
we see in Wi-Fi and Ethernet,
it just gets faster and faster
to transfer things.
And with Bluetooth, it went
from one megabits per second,
to three, to 54.
So you would expect that
version four is amazing.
Well, not really
what you expected.
And the reason for this,
why transfer speed was
cut down dramatically
and almost nonexistent,
is because two main factors--
power and cost.
And with all of these
low energy devices,
you want to make sure that
they use as less battery as
possible, so it can last without
being charged or connected
all the time.
And the other part is the
cost of producing these.
Producing something with a
lower transfer rate is cheaper.
So we can produce more
different devices and faster.
And through the
web, we've connected
through remote controlled
racecars, Bluetooth Low Energy
printers.
You might recognize this guy,
the BB8 remote control robot.
But it also connected
things like Dotty,
which is a Bluetooth LED
notification display, so
many different things.
So I wonder, should I be
brave enough and try a demo?
Yeah, thank you.
We'll see.
Well don't clap yet.
We'll see how it goes.
So this is a Bluetooth
Low Energy device
called a Play Bulb Candle.
It's basically just
setting the mood.
And you're going to have
different colors and all
of that.
But what I can do is that
I can get my mobile phone.
What I will be doing on my
phone is that I go into Chrome.
And I load a website.
And then I tap Connect.
And I get a list of available
Bluetooth devices nearby.
And I can see the
Play Bulb Candle here.
So now I pair with the Candle.
And now I can control
the colors of the Candle
but also what it looks like.
So I can change the effects.
I know.
It's amazing, right?
But the interesting thing
is that it's directly
from a web page, no extra
installs, no nothing.
If you want to use the services,
especially in most cases,
you only want to
use a service once.
You just go to URL and use it.
And you're done.
And since this is
supposed to be a candle,
do you think I can blow it out?
Let's try.
Ha, pretty cool.
[APPLAUSE]
And this demo is
available on GitHub.
And I can show you more
later if you want to.
And when you work with
Bluetooth Low Energy,
there are a few terms to
know, three different things.
You have the central device,
which is the phone in this case
.
You have the peripheral
device, which
is the candle or any kind of
Bluetooth Low Energy thing
that you connect to.
But you also have the GATT,
which is the generic ATTribute
profile.
So basically the Bluetooth
Low Energy device
has a GATT server.
And then you can
ask the GATT server
of this candle what
kind of services
and the characteristics
it supports.
So with the coder, you can
call navigator.Bluetooth.
And as you see, the first
parameter here is mandatory.
And it is what kind of
service you want to ask for.
And the reason for that is if
you asked for Bluetooth devices
close to you, you will
get a very long list.
So you only want to
ask for a device that
actually supports the thing
that you want to do right now.
Also the request
device method needs
to be called with a user action.
So basically you can't
just automatically do
this for a user.
They need to tap a button
or something like that.
This, again, like
the other ones,
it's only supported over HTTPS.
But if you want
to try it out, you
can also try it on local
host on your machines.
And it will work as well.
And once you actually manage
to pair with the device,
you connect to the GATT
server of that device.
And basically you get
back that connection.
And once you've gotten that,
you can get the primary service,
battery service in this case.
And once you have that, you
can check the characteristic,
which is the battery level.
Once you have that, you
can read out the value
and see, for instance, just the
actual battery of that device.
Same thing with the
candle and changing it,
the way we do it
with the candle is
that you have the primary
service, which is the candle
service UUID, and then
the characteristic, which
is candle caller UUID.
And then instead you call
the right value method.
So basically you
pass in the caller,
for instance, that you
want the candle to have.
And if you look at these values
like candle service UUID,
they seem magical.
How do you know what
it's actually named?
If you're lucky, when you get
a Bluetooth Low Energy device,
it will have a programming
guide with all these things
specified.
But if not, you can install
control software on Android
and also turn on the
developer options in Settings.
And then you can capture
all the Bluetooth packets.
And then you get the log.
And within that log,
you can actually
see the different values
and names of all of these.
You can also have
event listeners.
Like with this candle, I'm
glad it actually worked.
But when you blow
it out, you can
have an event listener to see if
the value of any characteristic
is changing.
So you can see, for instance,
oh, it was actually blown out.
Now I'm going to do
something else with it.
Then we have WebNFC coming.
And it's basically what
it says, that on the web,
you can connect
through NFC to devices
nearby and get JSON back
and then parse that format.
And I do recommend following
the work by a Danish friend
of mine, Kenneth Christiansen.
This is actually the best
picture I have of him.
So I worked a long time
to get a better one.
But I couldn't.
And you should follow
his work, because he's
working both with
the WebNFC stuff
but also something
called Generic Sensors.
And basically the idea
with Generic Sensors
is that you would have a
generally specified API
for different kinds of sensors.
So you could have direct tire
pressure sensor for your car.
So if you wanted,
through JavaScript,
to check the value of
your left front tire
or something like that,
you can get that back.
And also you could
work with other things
like geo location
sensors and other values
and get on error an on
change event handlers.
And the idea with this
and the previous example,
it could basically
be any sensor.
And it should be implemented
and accessed in the same way.
You just have the
name of the sensor
and then the same calls,
the same methods, et cetera.
And talking about
physical devices
and talking about
web Bluetooth, I
want to talk briefly about
another project called
Physical Web.
And Physical Web is
basically about beacons.
You would have really,
really small things
that they put out there.
And the only thing that they
do is that a broadcast a URL.
So if you're close to one
of these with your device,
you will get a notification
on your phone with the URL.
And then you tap
that notification.
And it will take
you to that URL.
And it could be any kind of
information in that page.
But the interesting
part is about,
with the physical
beacons, it's only things
that you are actually close to.
So if you would walk
around in a mall,
you can walk by a
store with shoes.
And it could send out a URL.
And you would tap that.
And it will tell you that
they have a sale today,
for instance.
Or if you're on
the train station,
you can get a notification.
And then you can follow the
URL and see the timetable.
Or parking your car,
you can actually
access the parking meter
from within the car
so you don't even
have to get out.
And you can pay for
parking, et cetera.
So it's an easy way of
just giving information
to people close to where
they are right now.
But it also in the future,
looking into interacting more
with these beacons
through something
called referring device.
And the idea with this is
that with the physical beacons
that you could connect to them
through their GATT server.
And then you can also start
to control things on them
or directly interface
with them through the web.
And we've seen a bunch of
experimental implementations
so far with web Bluetooth.
Chrome and Opera has had
the first implementations.
And we work on making
them more and more stable.
And we've seen a
really huge developer
interest with web Bluetooth and
the things that we can create.
We're hoping to see more
browsers start implementing it
soon as well.
I also want to talk about
virtual reality briefly.
And we've seen good
progress on 1.0 of the API.
So about two months
ago, the first version
landed in Firefox.
And they've been doing
really great work on v.r.
VR.
We're getting closer to that
as well with Chrome this year.
And Microsoft Edge has also
begun development on VR
in the browser.
And about six months ago,
we have a one time per year
our a big developer
conference called Google I/O.
And at Google I/O, we,
six months ago in May, we
announced something
called Daydream.
And basically what
Daydream is, it's
a specification
for VR experiences.
So it's more of having a
reference design for a headset
that should have a headband.
It should have a remote
control similar to this one.
And at the top of the remote
control, it's a clicker.
But it's also a touch pad.
So you can move your
thumb around and control
things and all of that.
And then you have below
that one the action button,
and then one home button.
And the first ones we shipped
was with one headset made out
of cloth, which is
soft and nice to wear,
because especially if you're
going to wear it over time
and watching videos or
something like that,
it should be comfortable and
not like a big piece of plastic
in your face.
People don't seem to like that.
But that's only
one of the options.
But we're seeing a number
of different providers,
from Samsung and LG and
more also building devices.
So it's not a Google-only thing.
But it's more of
something that will work
across the board on Android.
And you're going to see more
headsets, more remote controls,
and more experiences.
And if you're
interested in VR, I
do recommend a project by
Mozilla called A-Frame.
And it's designed by
the Mozilla VR team.
And basically what
it does is that it
wraps a library called 3.js
and WebGL in custom elements
in HTML.
So it's a really nice
way of getting started,
playing with it, see
if you like it or not.
A few months ago
as well, we also
shipped something called
VR View for the web.
So if you have a content
like 360 images or 360 videos
or something like that,
basically what you do
is that you embed it in your
web page with an I-frame.
You point to a URL.
And you have a small JavaScript
library to handle it.
And if you're on a desktop
computer, and if you click,
you can click and drag
and look around and then
see what it's like.
But also if you have a VR
viewer, Cardboard or similar,
you can just put your phone in.
And then you get a full on VR
experience with that as well.
So it's a nice easy
way of getting started.
And especially for hotels or
travel websites and all that,
getting more of a feeling
for what it's like
for where you're going.
And we've also seen interesting
implications from Oculus.
One of the co-founders of
Oculus is a big supporter
of VR on the web as well.
And what Facebook announced
about one, two months ago
at their conference
on Oculus was also
showing more of an
effort of supporting web.
And also, and it's been said
before today, why we're here
is that we're really
here to, of course,
try and tell you about
some of the things
that we are working on,
but more importantly
to hear from you what
you need, what we can do
to make things better for you.
What are the biggest
challenges as developers?
What are the things that we
need to do better for you?
And also with bug reporting,
for instance and those
things helps a lot.
I should also mention with
all the different browser
vendors, for a long time,
this is what it looked like.
You had the big five, the
big browsers on desktop.
But that's not really
where we are anymore.
If we look on mobile, there's
so many different options
right now for users.
And you would have anything from
QQ to UC to Samsung browser,
and much, much more.
And I think this
is really what's
both important and
beautiful about the web,
that the users have so
many different options.
They can use whatever they
like and what they prefer.
So the web to me is kind
of like a mix of very
many different kinds of things.
I have no idea
what this is about.
But at the same time
that's the beauty.
It's a mix of all
kinds of experiences.
And that's the way it should be.
And summarizing all this, the
way I see the future of the web
is not necessarily going
crazy with technology.
But it's about offering
a way better experience
for users and for developers.
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: [SPEAKING MANDARIN]
AUDIENCE: My English
is not so good.
But your talk is very
important for me.
You just show a web application
to control the Bluetooth light.
And I see the code is
use GATT tools library.
I find this library
very long time.
Where did you find it?
ROBERT NYMAN: A library for--
AUDIENCE: GATT tools.
ROBERT NYMAN: I
haven't used that one.
AUDIENCE: What?
ROBERT NYMAN: So--
sorry, say again?
AUDIENCE: What?
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: [SPEAKING MANDARIN]
AUDIENCE: GATT tools, G-A-T-T.
ROBERT NYMAN: Oh, like
the GATT, the GATT server?
Oh, OK.
So if I understand correctly,
so you have, like with this,
it has GATT server,
which will tell you
what you can access on it.
And depending on what Bluetooth
device you buy, some of them
have manuals or guides
telling you how to access it
and what it's all called.
But sometimes you need to
turn on logging and Android
and developer tools and do a
packet sniffing to get the log.
And then you need to read
through it to find the names.
We can probably find as well
some good option for you
where to get started, if that's
what you're trying to find.
AUDIENCE: Is this
tools open source?
ROBERT NYMAN: I believe so.
I can check.
One of my colleagues is
the Mr. web Bluetooth.
So I can ask him about
the best tools for that.
And then I can
share it with you.
AUDIENCE: Could you show the
GitHub that you just showed?
ROBERT NYMAN: Not
right now, because Pete
wanted his computer back.
If you come up, I can
share with you later.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ROBERT NYMAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So you have talked
about how to make logging
into a website simple.
So I think that Turing test
also block our log in a lot.
So my question is what is
the future for Turing test?
Do you think how some
way to make it easier?
ROBERT NYMAN: So the
future of the Turing test?
The Turing test.
I think I can't really answer
what the future of that test
would be.
It's an interesting
conversation.
But you should ask
Sam about that.
But I think it's an
interesting question.
I think more and more, like
in all kinds of experiences,
it's making more and more
automatic and personalized
without having you
think about it.
You assume that things work
according to what you expect.
SPEAKER 2: I think
an interesting part
of that is thinking about what's
the future of the web on voice
interaction devices,
on Echo or Google Home.
Where's the web?
There's no reason why there's
not a future on those devices.
But how will that work?
And when that becomes
something that
might pass the Turing test,
that's interesting I think.
AUDIENCE: Here's
another question.
So the audience is
interested in how do we
calculate the stats about
the most popular password,
like in 2015?
So what's the source?
ROBERT NYMAN: So
how we calculate
the most popular password?
It's a secret.
No, there is--
I can dig it up.
But there are resources
that do surveys and tests
and all that to calculate that.
So we actually don't-- we
or not anyone else, I hope,
know the password of every
user in the entire world.
SPEAKER 3: I just
wanted to toss on that.
A lot of that data
comes from websites
that have been either leaked
or hacked their password lists.
And then people then
just compile them.
So that's not anything
that we came up with.
That's something from
an external site.
ROBERT NYMAN: We don't
know your password.
We don't want to
AUDIENCE: Hi, I
have one question
about password to another one,
and about Android Pay, the web
pay.
Sorry You say Chrome will
save the password, user name.
I'm kind of worried about safe.
Is that enough safe about
a password in the web pay?
ROBERT NYMAN: So the
way we store that,
even before Payments, we've
been storing passwords
through Chrome for a long time.
And of course, we
can't see the passwords
that are being all
encrypted and beyond us.
You need to login as a user
to be able to use that.
Like in Chrome, you
can go into Settings
and see all the
password that you saved.
But you need to
enter your own master
password to be able to
see them or read them out.
And it's the same thing
for Payments as well.
So for instance, the way it
works in Chrome right now,
so for me, let's say I
would want to book my flight
to come here.
I go into the airline
company's website.
And I see that form.
And then Chrome understands
that the credit card
field is a credit card field.
So if I double
click on that field,
it pops up the credit cards
that I have saved in there.
So I can't see
the entire number.
But I can see the last four
digits or something like that.
So let's say I choose
my credit card.
And it gets auto filled.
I still need to
fill out the code
on the back side
of the credit card
to verify that it's actually me.
So you have small means of
still being in the control.
Pin codes are similar,
verifying that--
AUDIENCE: That means the
password is not that important.
ROBERT NYMAN: It depends.
But I think, with any
kind of password handling,
it's extremely sensitive.
And of course, for us it's
very important to make sure
that it's secure for users.
I don't know how many
years people have
been able to save passwords
in Chrome and Firefox
and all the other
browsers, Safari.
But there are methods
of making sure that they
are as safe as possible.
So like Pete said, if
it would get hacked,
it's so safe and encrypted.
So no one should be able
to actually read it out.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: [SPEAKING MANDARIN]
So if no more questions,
you can go to first floor.
There's a party.
Enjoy.
[APPLAUSE]